distant horizons and unconquered heights
have been tempting mankind since times
immemorial
inquiring minds have always been
restless in their search for the secret
of the genesis of our world and people
have always had the urge to learn about
it and to try to explain it
this tenacity has allowed us first to
explore our native planet and then
venture out beyond
into freezing and forbidding space
today i invite you to join us on an
imaginary trip beyond the boundaries of
the universe
we will start out far away from the
earth near the first space probes that
left our planet a long while ago
whizzing at super luminal speeds we will
cross interstellar space in the blink of
an eye and visit several remarkable
stars not far from our system
after that we will make beetlejuice's
acquaintance a dying star that will help
us understand stellar evolution better
and then we'll see some of the loneliest
and most mysterious space objects
rogue planets
the next item on our tour will be a
brief visit to a few places beyond the
milky way we'll take a closer look at
several nearest galaxies and then go to
the most dangerous formations in the
universe
bizarre black holes
eventually we will travel as far from
our native planet as to reach the limits
of observable space
we will not only brush the boundary but
even make it beyond the event horizon in
our attempt to appreciate the true
magnitude of the universe
this is going to be a long trip let's
get ready off we go
[Music]
cosmo
the first in outer space
roughly half a year before this video
was posted on the 15th of april 2021 the
automatic space probe new horizons
became the fifth spacecraft in the
history of the humanity to go beyond the
point of 50 astronomical units from the
sun
it was the voyages that had crossed this
mark before with the probes pioneer 10
and pioneer 11 the first ever to do so
none of these space wanderers are likely
to ever return to the earth
with some of them still active on their
missions others have gone quiet forever
spacecraft
new horizons
start of mission 19th of january 2006
distance to earth 52 astronomical units
spade
14 kilometers per second or three
astronomical units per year main goal
pluto and sharon
mission status successfully completed
condition operational
just like most other interplanetary
space probes new horizons performed a
gravity assist maneuver near jupiter
before setting out to its target
not only did it greatly boost the
spacecraft's speed but also allowed it
to capture high quality images of the
largest planet in the solar system
alongside its satellites
besides the probe's cameras captured the
first video ever of an erupting volcano
on the surface of jupiter's satellite io
after the gravity boost had been
completed the probe made for the main
target pluto
the spacecraft reached the planetoids
environs in january 2015. the mission's
main goal was to explore pluto and
sharon from different perspectives that
involved taking photos of and mapping
these remote space object surfaces
in addition the probe estimated the
magnetic fields values and the solar
wind activity close to the objects and
collected information about their
atmospheres and surface reflection
properties
it goes without saying that the program
also involved search for pluto's as yet
undetected satellites and more accurate
measurements of pluto's orbits
parameters
having completed the main mission the
probe continued to be useful
it flew beyond pluto's orbit and went on
to explore objects in the kuiper belt
that is how images of kawa r1 and
darakoth were produced
thanks to the probe's cameras the
distances to the star's proxima centauri
and wolf 359 were measured
unfortunately the radio isotope
generator on board the spacecraft is
expected to start running low from 2026
and eventually all the meters will
switch off one after another
new horizons will continue on its way
beyond the boundaries of the solar
system and by the year 2038 the distance
between the probe and the sun will have
grown to be a hundred astronomical units
by that time the energy generator on
board the spacecraft will have stopped
operating completely and it will be
impossible to get any connection with it
following a hyperbolic orbit new
horizons will exit our system never to
come back
the same thing happened with two other
probes pioneer 10 and pioneer 11.
they hit an escape trajectory from the
solar system a while ago
in fact they were the first automatic
space probes ever to be sent into
interstellar space by humans
spacecraft pioneer 10
start of mission
3rd of march 1972 distance to earth
127 astronomical units
speed approximately 12 kilometers per
second or two and a half astronomical
units per year main goal jupiter
mission status successfully completed
condition not operational
the spacecraft reached jupiter's system
on the 4th of december 1973 after
completing a
641 day journey through space
during the mission images of the gas
giant's surface and its largest
satellites were beamed back to the earth
and the planet's atmospheric composition
and magnetic field were gauged in
addition jupiter was found to emit two
and a half times more thermal energy
than it receives from the sun the data
unique at the time became the basis for
understanding the makeup of gas giants
and their satellites
the trajectory of the second probe
pioneer 11 through space passed jupiter
2 but its main target was the other gas
giant of our system
saturn
the probe's scientific instruments
gauged the planet's magnetic field and
the cameras on board took quite a few
snapshots not only of the gas giant
itself and its system of rings but also
two of its satellites titan and mimas
according to the estimates the current
distance between pioneer 11 and the
center of our system is around 106
astronomical units
on completing their main mission both
probes continued on their way moving
further and further away from the sun
unfortunately both of them are out of
range now with the last signal from
pioneer 10 received back in 2003
the last signal from pioneer 11 was
received in 1995
supposedly both of them are now rapidly
moving beyond the boundaries of the
solar system
incidentally having no chance of ever
catching up with either of the two
probes we're going to talk about next
the pioneers were launched at a much
earlier date
spacecraft voyager 1
start of mission
5th of september 1977
distance to earth
154 astronomical units
speed
around 17 kilometers per second or 3.6
astronomical units per year
main goal jupiter and saturn
mission status successfully completed
condition
not fully operational
the contribution of voyager 1 to the
solar system's exploration can hardly be
overestimated
it is thanks to this probe that several
new jupiter satellites were discovered
alongside its ring system which was big
news
the voyager's cameras captured volcano
eruptions on io and provided hard
evidence that jupiter's great red spot
is an enormous storm
the probe beamed back hundreds of photos
of the largest planet of our solar
system and its satellites
after the spacecraft crossed neptune's
orbit the meters on board sent back a
great amount of valuable data about
interstellar plasma voyager 1 left both
the kuiper belt and the heliopause
behind a long while ago and is now
rapidly crossing the area of the solar
system's scattered disc
making for the inner boundary of the
hypothetical oort cloud it is not only
the remotest man-made object in space
but also the fastest of all the
spacecraft on their way to exit our
system
being the first space probe to have
traveled that far from the center of the
solar system
voyager 1 offered scientists a unique
opportunity to study the heliopause
this is the area around our sun where
solar wind pressure and interstellar gas
pressure balance when the charged
particles emitted by the star collide
with rarefied plasma elaborate
structures form out of elementary
particles and magnetic fields
studying them is crucial for
understanding processes taking place in
the universe
unfortunately by around the year 2025
the power of the radioisotope
thermoelectric generators on board the
probe will have run out completely and
the connection will have been lost in
300 years voyager 1 is estimated to
reach the inner boundary of the
hypothetical oort cloud it will take the
spacecraft approximately 30 000 years to
go clean through
and after that it will fly beyond the
boundaries of the solar system 10 000
years later still the probe will fly by
the star glissa 445 at a distance of 1.6
light years and then it will eventually
get lost in the infinite depths of outer
space
[Music]
speaking about voyager 1 we can't but
mention its twin launched from the earth
on the 20th of august 1977.
voyager 2 had saturn uranus and neptune
for its targets but it also approached
jupiter for a gravity boost it's the
images taken by this probe that allowed
scientists to assume that there are
subsurface oceans on ganymede and europa
on reaching saturn
voyager 2 gauged the gas giant's
temperature and magnetic field and
discovered several new satellites it
goes without saying that lots of
snapshots were taken of both saturn's
surface and its rings
next in line on the probe's way were
uranus and neptune
the flyby yielded a great number of
unique snapshots and in total 17 of the
two planet satellites were discovered
also it was found that both uranus and
neptune have ring systems
neptune's gravitational influence the
spacecraft changed its trajectory and
left the ecliptic plane
this meant that voyager 2 wouldn't be
able to approach the other objects in
the solar system but it still had other
exciting things to look forward to thus
the probe was to collect invaluable data
about interstellar plasma and cosmic
wind as well as to measure distances to
stars and explore the heliosphere
the probe is currently as far as 120
astronomical units away from the center
of our system with a distance growing by
15.37 kilometers every second
it's going to take it around 42 000
years to approach ross 248
a dim red dwarf in the constellation
andromeda
the minimal distance between voyager 2
and the star will be about 1.7 light
years and around 300 000 years since its
launch chances are it will fly by sirius
at a distance of 4.3 light years
unfortunately it is impossible to
distinguish such a tiny object from the
earth that far away
we live at the dawn of space exploration
and interplanetary space probes are just
mankind's first timid steps in exploring
the infinite universe
it is hard to predict their fate
they may be smashed on collision with
the celestial body or they may be
recaptured by our distant descendants
who will have advanced interstellar
travel technologies to the point of
being able to catch up with the probes
for all we know they might recover them
from space and put on display in a
museum
but it is more likely that the fragile
apparatuses are destined to drift on for
years and years through the lifeless
expanses
and millions of years later radioactive
rays and rare particles of cosmic dust
whizzing through the probes time and
time again will eventually wear them
down to threadbare debris to be
scattered across the depths of the
universe without a trace
there are approximately 1
400 stellar systems in space within the
radius of 50 light years from the solar
system
some of them are multiple and contain
two and more objects which makes the
overall number of our stellar neighbors
over two thousand
these are all sorts of stars from dim
red dwarves to dazzling giants whose
temperatures are beyond our imagination
the incredible scale and great abundance
of space objects and all their diversity
can't but amaze
life's too short to give account of each
and every one of them
right now we're going to travel at
incredible speeds by far faster than the
speed of light
it will take us just a few minutes to
cover dozens of light years of space
we'll get to check out quite a few
remarkable space objects around the
solar system
other worlds and stars are already
waiting
after we fly round proxima centauri a
detour of 11 light-years that would have
passed in the blink of an eye we're in
the environs of the dim red dwarf known
as ros128
we can't see it from the earth with a
naked eye
on pre-possessing though it may seem
there is an earth-like exoplanet dubbed
ros128b orbiting this star
this exoplanet is one of the closest to
us
unlike the yet closer and cooler proxima
centauri b
the temperature on dros 128b is
relatively moderate ranging from -60 to
plus 21 degrees celsius
assuming its surface to be identical to
that of our planet which absorbs 70
percent of the light shed on it the
equilibrium temperature of ros 128b is
estimated at around 7 degrees celsius
it is 8 degrees cooler than that of
today's earth but quite enough to
sustain life
the exoplanet's mass is roughly 35
percent bigger than that of the earth
the radius hasn't been accurately
measured at this point
but provided the planet's composition is
similar to our earth's its diameter is
supposed to be roughly 10 percent bigger
than that of the earth the free-fall
acceleration on its surface is expected
to be just 12 percent bigger than that
on our planet
if all these estimations are correct
then the conditions on the surface of
ros128b are supposed to be comparable
with those on the earth
besides the system is rapidly moving to
meet the sun
in just 79 000 years it will be closer
to us than proxima centauri which is
moving away from us
quite like most exoplanets we know of
ros 128b is located quite close to its
host star
the distance from it to the center of
the system is just 0.05 astronomical
units or 20 times shorter than the
distance between the earth and the sun
it takes the exoplanet slightly under 10
days to complete a full orbit around its
star
it is also thought that it must be
tidally locked
speaking about its host star ros 128 its
mass is approximately 17 percent that of
the sun with the radius measuring around
0.2 that of the sun
the star's surface temperature is twice
as low as out of the sun
at
3192 kelvin and its luminosity is
roughly 300 times lower than that of the
sun it's worth mentioning that dros 128
is a comparatively quiet star
with its luminosity quite stable and
regular it hardly ever flares up or
emits stellar matter so pernicious for
all living things
moving on through space 12 light years
in the direction pointing away from the
sun we will see lightens star also known
as gj273
it boasts one of the largest planetary
systems detected in the space nearest to
us
the star itself is a red dwarf of an
orange hue whose mass is just 25 percent
that of the sun
its radius is three times smaller than
that of the sun and its luminosity is
435 times lower so it's hardly
surprising that it can only be seen
through a telescope
it is quite an exciting star because
there are as many as four objects
detected in its environs two of which
are confirmed exoplanets
the other two are still prospective
candidates awaiting confirmation
the first confirmed exoplanet was dubbed
light and b it was detected thanks to
high precision measurement of the star's
proper motion the object's mass is
estimated to be about 2.89 times that of
the earth its radius is 35 percent
bigger than that of our planet
this makes the object a super earth and
its surface gravity may turn out to be
suitable for humans
the distance between the system's center
and light and b equals roughly 0.1
astronomical units although the amount
of light received by the exoplanet from
its parent star is comparable with that
received by us from the sun
thus light and b lies in its star's
habitable zone and may well be
considered a potential candidate for
searching for alien life the equilibrium
surface temperature of the planet is 259
to 292 kelvin or minus 14 to plus 19
degrees celsius
this makes the conditions on light and
big quite suitable for humans
the other confirmed exoplanet in the
system is light and sea
with this space object's mass similar to
that of the earth it lies much closer to
its host star the exact parameters of
its orbit haven't been defined yet but
it is known that it takes the object
just 4.7 days to complete a full orbit
around its system's center
it is likely that this is a scorching
hot and harsh celestial body without any
atmosphere with one on the same side
facing the star at all times
the two other objects in the system were
discovered in 2019 and are still
awaiting confirmation of their status
according to preliminary estimates there
are ice giants with masses from five to
15 times out of the earth with the radii
of their orbits lying within 0.8
astronomical units their orbital periods
cannot be over
558 days
lighten is a relatively cold star and
with these two objects lying beyond its
habitable zone their temperatures are
almost certainly extremely low
it goes without saying that at this
stage these two candidates still want
further exploration
moving on and away from the lighting
system we will come across a star known
as out air
lying 16.8 light years away from the
earth it is a bright white blue star
its mass is around 1.8 that of the sun
and its age is estimated at around 1.2
billion years
this star's luminosity is 11 times that
of the sun
which makes it one of the most
conspicuous objects in our night sky
another curious feature about air is its
rotation which is remarkably fast
thus it spins on its axis approximately
67 times faster than the sun it
completes a full rotation within
slightly less than 9 hours the velocity
of star material at the equator equals
about 286 kilometers per second due to
this outstandingly rapid rotation the
star's shape is far from an ideal sphere
the star's equatorial diameter is 22
percent bigger than the distance between
its poles and is roughly twice the
diameter of the sun
the star's shape can't but affect its
temperature and luminosity which also
differ in its different areas
the stellar matter in the equatorial
zone of the star is noticeably colder
and darker than in the poles
the temperature of the equator is just
6900 kelvin
the poles meanwhile are as hot as 8 500
kelvin which is around 8
200 degrees celsius
interestingly the fact that altair has
an irregular shape was first arrived at
following theoretical calculations
only later in 2007 was it finally
confirmed after an image of the star was
produced where it is seen to have a
disc-like shape
actually altair happened to become the
first star beyond the solar system whose
surface had been imaged
unfortunately no planet has been
detected in altair's environs still
observations show rings or a fog of gas
enveloping the star
altair's light is dispersed in these
structures which produces a curious
effect this major interference of light
results in a humongous rainbow around
the star
on the downside however even though it
looks fascinating and majestic it partly
conceals this star and so greatly
hampers studying it
as we carry on on our way through space
we will get as far as thermal health
lying 25 light years away from the earth
this stellar system consists of three
components for a long time the three
components making it up used to be
considered mutually independent space
objects
then in 2013 evidence showed that they
are in fact gravitationally bound
forming a large and single structure in
space
thermal howd is probably the widest
multiple star system located close to
ours the biggest distance between its
components reaches 3.2 light years
incidentally almost 11 lunar disks may
be placed in our night sky between the
remotest objects in the thermal health
system
the largest most well-known and
well-seen component of the system is
referred to as thermal health a
it's a young and hot star whose mass is
92 percent bigger than that of the sun
with its radius measuring around 1.85
times that of the sun
it was this star that people have
referred to as thermal health since
ancient times quite unaware of the fact
that there are other not so easily
observable components in this system
the star's luminosity is remarkably high
at 16 times that of the sun
its temperature is estimated at roughly
8 500 kelvin or 8
200 degrees celsius
thermal health could be as old as 400 to
480 million years
according to today's models of stellar
evolution the star may grow to be around
1 billion years old
on reaching this age it will more likely
than not go supernova and turn into a
white dwarf
thermal health a is surrounded by a disk
of protoplanetary gas and dust
divided into several segments its inner
radius is 133 astronomical units with a
width measuring about 25 astronomical
units
this disk is thought to be an active
stellar nursery with celestial bodies
regularly born there
that is why it is an area of keen
interest for astronomers
it used to be thought that there was a
massive planet lurking somewhere in
thermal health's environs it was even
given a name
dagon
however further observations showed that
there was hardly any planet there after
all
it must have been a wide cloud of dust
that was taken for an exoplanet it would
have originated on collision of
asteroids and comets
point nine light years away from the
main component of the system there lies
former held b
also known as tw pisces or striny
it's an orange dwarf with a mass around
70 percent that of the sun with its
radius roughly 63 percent that of the
sun
the star's surface temperature is
estimated at approximately 4700 kelvin
which is
4400 degrees celsius
interestingly the star's luminosity is
much lower than that of the sun
our host star is five times brighter
in 2019 on carrying out spectral and
proper motion analysis scientists put
forward the suggestion that there might
be a celestial body as heavy as 0.6 to
1.9 jupiter masses orbiting the star the
existence of this body still remains to
be confirmed and its exact orbits
parameters calculated precisely
at this point preliminary estimations
show that it should take the
hypothetical planet 25 years to complete
a full orbit around its host star
the third star in the thermal health
system is lp876-10
it is a red dwarf lying two and a half
light years away from the main component
of the system the star is five times
lighter than the sun and its surface
temperature is slightly over 3100 kelvin
it takes lp
876-10 approximately 20 million years to
complete a full orbit around thermal
health a apparently the red dwarf would
have orbited its big brother just 22
times since the birth of the system as
for planets or exoplanet candidates none
of these have so far been detected near
the star
still observations allow us to suppose
that there is a cloud of gas and dust
around it whose radius is anything from
10 to 40 astronomical units
our next and final destination for today
is 37.3 light years away from the earth
that's the distance we would have
covered now to reach arcturus the
brightest star in the northern
hemisphere and the fourth brightest star
in the night sky
the star is the main component of a
binary star system it is an orange giant
whose life is now slowly drawing to a
close most of its hydrogen has already
been transformed into helium and now the
star is busy burning the remains of its
stellar fuel and gradually expanding in
size
arcturus is also the brightest star of a
great stellar stream named in its honor
this gargantuan structure is in fact the
debris of a dwarf galaxy absorbed by the
milky way some 2 billion years ago
it contains 53 stars
most of them are old and dim and not
nearly as impressive as arcturus
arcturus emits 170 times as much
luminous energy as the sun although its
surface temperature is much lower at
just
4251 kelvin
it is thought that this giant used to be
quite like our sun because its mass is
just 10 bigger but what with the
inevitable depletion of its stellar fuel
and the inner pressure of its scorching
hot plasma the star turned into an
orange giant whose radius is now 25
times that of the sun
according to today's theory of stellar
evolution
this is something that our sun is
expected to go through in the distant
future too
actress's age is gauged at anything from
six to eight and a half billion years
it is hard to predict when it will go
supernova at the end of its life cycle
but it will happen quite soon in
astronomical terms
shedding its outer layers arcturus will
become a scorching hot white dwarf
destined to slowly cool off in the
course of billions of years to follow
the second component of the system is
barely visible against the background of
its giant companion
this small star with luminosity 20 times
lower than that of arcturus lies so
close to it that it's hardly possible to
define its parameters
even if some planets did manage to form
in this stellar system many millions of
years ago they must have been absorbed
by arcturus itself
either way no objects have been detected
in the stars environs at this point
the end of 2019 astronomical
observatories report a sudden decrease
in the luminosity of the star known as
betelgeuse observations show that its
luminosity dropped to 36 of the standard
value within a matter of a couple of
months
some scientists are talking about an
upcoming supernova which will be the
brightest object in the night sky
disturbingly the gamma-ray flow emitted
by the explosion is thought to be
potentially dangerous for life on our
planet
april 2020
astronomers assure the general public
that beetlejuice has recovered its
luminosity to the standard value it may
still go supernova at any moment but
there is no way to predict this event
with any degree of certainty
assumptions about reasons for such
anomalous fading are put forward
according to the most popular hypothesis
it was caused by a giant cloud of gas
and dust ejected by beetlejuice in the
direction of the sun very recently
june 2021
the assumption is confirmed by data from
earth-based telescopes
astronomers keep observing the object
while astrophysicists model out the
processes occurring in its interior
before we attempt to get to the bottom
of what was taking place
it's a good idea to be aware of what
beetlejuice is like
this object falls into the category of
red supergiants and is in the final
stage of its life cycle according to
today's theory of stellar evolution
with its luminosity and radius
constantly changing its outer layers are
highly unstable
the star regularly emits millions of
tons of scorching gas into space
and this forms gargantuan prominences
as they cool off they contribute to the
gas nebula surrounding beetlejuice
the star's mass is around 17 times that
of the sun and its diameter has by now
been gauged only roughly at 700 to 880
times that of the sun hypothetically if
beetlejuice were to be placed in the
center of our system it would swallow up
all the planets as far as mars as well
as most of the asteroid belt
it should be mentioned that the star has
no clearly defined edge because its
outer layers are extremely rarified
besides the object is shrouded in a
gargantuan gas nebula made up of cooled
off prominences or protuberances and
particles of stellar wind at the same
time the density of stellar matter on
the conventional edges of the star is
only slightly higher than that of the
nebula
beetlejuice is a remarkably bright star
its minimal luminosity is 90 000 times
higher than that of the sun while its
maximal luminosity is a staggering 150
000 times higher
interestingly the star's temperature is
not that great considering it ranges
from 3400 to 3800 kelvin which
corresponds to the red spectral band
there are barely predictable processes
running in the unstable outer layers of
the star they are capable of elaborately
changing the object's luminosity
the main pulsation period of the star is
approximately 420 days but less distinct
cycles of longer and smaller periods can
be singled out too besides unpredictable
flares and dimming of the star can be
observed from time to time because this
star is so unstable it is extremely
difficult to calculate the distance
between us according to the estimates
offered by the coriolis satellite in
2020 the distance between the sun and
beetlejuice is anything from 500 to 650
light years
according to today's notions of stellar
evolution
betelgeuse would have formed around
eight and a half million years ago and
its original mass wouldn't have been
over 20 solar masses
its life cycle would have started in a
giant cloud of interstellar gas that
would have been gradually compressed and
heated up by gravity forces that is how
the protostar the progenitor of
beetlejuice was born at a certain point
the temperature and pressure in its
interior reached high enough values to
unleash a chain reaction of hydrogen
transforming into helium
moments later
the thermonuclear interaction consumed
the entire astronomical body and a new
star flared up in the night sky
this is how the longest period in the
life of any star begins
the main sequence stage
throughout this time merging of hydrogen
atoms nuclei that produce helium is the
main energy source for them
admittedly the heavier a star the faster
this process runs
life expectancy of massive stars like
beetlejuice is a measly several million
years whereas red dwarves remain active
for billions of years
either way
over 90 percent of a star's life passes
in the main sequence stage
gradually accumulating
helium is drawn to the object's center
to form a helium core what happens to
the star next depends almost entirely on
its mass
for example stars with masses not over
20 percent that of the sun do not go
supernova at the end of their existence
unlike more massive stars having
eventually run out of almost all of
their hydrogen they slowly turn into
blue dwarfs hot and comparatively small
astronomical objects
however the minimal time it takes to
complete this transformation is around a
trillion years which is 72 times the
assumed age of the universe which is why
it is doubtful that any blue dwarf will
be discovered today
after hydrogen supplies are depleted
thermonuclear reactions in the star will
stop and it will become a white dwarf
made up of 99 of helium
ahead are trillions of years of slow
fading and cooling until a tepid black
dwarf is left instead which is barely
visible through telescopes
if an object's mass lies in the range
from 0.2 to 8 solar masses its evolution
goes through more elaborate processes
helium which is produced as a result of
thermonuclear reactions adds to the
star's core while gravity forces
compress it and heat it up more and more
at a certain point there occurs a
reaction of helium nucleis merging which
produces carbon the star begins to
expand its radius grows as well and the
temperature of the outer layers drops in
this case the object turns into a red
giant or sub-giant comparatively light
stars with masses not exceeding 50
percent that of the sun can at sustain
conditions necessary for the chain
reaction of helium and carbon
transformations like these are quite
irregular in such objects
as for heavier objects reactions
occurring the star's core may run longer
and produce not only carbon and oxygen
but also heavier elements like nickel
and iron
eventually the star sheds its outer
layers and what is left is a white dwarf
enveloped in a planetary nebula if the
initial mass of the original star wasn't
more than half that of the sun it will
mostly be made up of helium with just a
small ratio of heavier elements in its
composition
if on the other hand the star was
heavier than that the white dwarf would
be mostly made up of oxygen and carbon
however with the original star having
been heavy enough it will include neon
magnesium and even iron evolution of
massive objects has its laws
the heavier a star the more massive its
core
with the mass of a star eight or more
times that of the sun its core might get
over the so-called chandra shaker limit
which is 1.4 times the mass of the sun
in this case forces of internal
electromagnetic repulsion are not strong
enough to compensate for gravitational
compression it takes a few seconds for
the core to shrink pulling the outer
layers in its wake
the exceptionally powerful compression
heats up the core to temperatures of
hundreds of millions kelvin and
literally crams electrons into atoms
nuclei
this turns part of the electrons into
neutrons and produces great amounts of
neutrinos
even a dense material like that is not
able to hold back the most elusive
particle in the universe
in a few seconds time neutrinos break
away from the collapsing star and escape
taking some thermal energy with them
as a result the star experiences
extremely powerful internal pressure
as the closely packed protons repel each
other with a great force that is why the
core goes on to expand as rapidly as it
shrank a few seconds previously and this
produces a tremendous shock wave in the
material surrounding it
as a result a tremendously powerful
explosion occurs which is capable of
hurling the star's outer layers enormous
distances away
its flames can unleash reactions that
are impossible anywhere else that is how
heavy elements are produced like gold
lead or uranium the nebula formed as a
by-product gradually cools off and
disperses to form separate clouds which
are later compressed by gravity forces
and transform into new stars and planets
where the star has been there remains a
tiny but extremely heavy object referred
to as a neutron star if the original
star's mass was over 18 to 20 times that
of the sun on explosion its core is
supposed to shrink to form a black hole
a bizarre object that distorts time and
space around it
mathematical modelling shows that
particularly large stars with masses
over a hundred times the mass of the sun
may hypothetically be destroyed by the
blast completely
in this case all the material they're
made up of will be scattered by the
shock wave many light years around or
else be transformed into extremely
powerful electromagnetic radiation
an electromagnetic impulse from a
supernova is capable of covering
hundreds of light years
at first the radiation is characterized
by incredible force annihilating all
living things on its way
[Music]
however with the covered distance
growing the density of the flow
decreases and the lethal rays gradually
disperse in space
estimates show that a star similar to
beetlejuice may be a threat to anything
within the radius of up to 100 light
years
it is absolutely impossible to tell when
this star will go supernova but it is
likely to do so in the nearest hundred
thousand years according to some
estimates beetlejuice may flare up as
brightly as the full moon the dying star
will remain the dominating object in our
night sky for a while and then will
gradually fade
the object will not be visible to the
naked eye anymore and only the most
powerful telescopes will be able to
distinguish the radiation emitted by the
tiny neutron star
if the mass of beetlejuice is actually
bigger than is assumed now
it may leave a black hole after going
supernova
in this scenario the energy flare will
be by far smaller and the site much less
impressive
either way there is no threat to the
earth beetlejuice lies too far away from
the solar system and a gamma-ray flare
that will accompany the supernova will
not cause us any harm the material
ejected by the explosion will reach the
environs of our system only in 6 million
years its speed is estimated to be
around 13 kilometers per second and will
be thwarted by solar wind before getting
as far as the inner areas of the system
with all today's successes in science
the dark depths of limitless space still
harbor myriads of mysteries and hazards
that is why people keep studying the sky
as diligently as thousands of years ago
in search of answers to their questions
and the gloomy boundless abyss of
interstellar space is as scary as it is
appealing
who knows
maybe at some point it will provide an
answer to a really major question
assumptions about the existence of space
objects the size of a planet which are
independent from any star have been
around for a long time
such celestial objects freely drifting
around interstellar space are referred
to as orphan free-floating or rogue
planets
astronomical bodies of this kind emit
very little thermal and light energy
into space around them it is suggested
that there are no bodies in their close
proximity they could clearly interact
with or be bound to
that is why it is hardly surprising that
these objects are so difficult to detect
the first potential representatives of
this class of planets were spotted as
recently as in the early 21st century
the warmest rogue planets can be
detected with infrared telescopes and
others thanks to something called the
gravitational microlensing effect
as one would expect
this class of celestial objects is one
of the most mysterious and understudied
today only three astronomical bodies can
be classified as rogue planets with a
sufficient degree of certainty with the
overall number of rogue planet
candidates over two dozen
incidentally according to the analysis
of data collected in the course of the
ogle project the milky way may
supposedly be home to up to a hundred
billion objects of this class
this may only mean that right now we're
at the very beginning of an upcoming
series of discoveries in this field
our notions of what rogue planets are
like have long been based purely on
assumptions and hypotheses
with the technological advancement of
highly sensitive observation equipment
there arose opportunities to put them to
the test in practice
the rogue planet lying closest to the
earth among those already confirmed is
known as wise 0855-0714
7.27 light years away from the sun it
was detected in 2014 with a wise orbital
infrared telescope
the astronomical body cannot be seen
through optical telescopes as it emits
no visible light to speak of
the reason for this is its extremely low
temperature
from 225 to 260 kelvin
or 48 to 13 degrees celsius below zero
in terms of its parameters it resembles
a cooled off gas giant and its age
cannot be under a billion years
the rogue planet is mostly made up of
hydrogen
however in 2016 the gemini observatory
produced evidence of the presence of
large amounts of water in its atmosphere
it is suggested that water is condensed
into clouds made up of tiniest particles
of ice
today it hasn't been established for
certain how this object came to be
there are currently two versions
suggested by researchers
according to the first one a celestial
object like that starts its life cycle
in the protoplanetary disk of a regular
planetary system
mathematical modeling of this process
shows that if the original cloud of gas
and dust is heavy enough it is highly
likely that at least one planet will be
ejected beyond the system
the celestial object may also be forced
out of its stars environs if another
massive star passes it by or else if its
planetary system collides with another
system
the chances of events like that are
admittedly comparatively
small the other version has it that the
space object was born just like any
other star on compression of
interstellar gas
at the same time the mass of the object
proved to be too small to unleash any
thermonuclear reactions in its interior
it goes without saying that in this
manner it may turn out only as a gas
giant or a brown dwarf but not a rocky
planet similar to the earth
some researchers don't agree that these
objects should be seen as rogue planets
and classify them as sub-brown dwarfs
instead
others suggest using the term planimo
for all interstellar wanderers that
don't show any thermonuclear activity
bearing in mind today's notions of the
makeup of brown dwarfs and gas giants we
may estimate the mass of wise 0855-0714
at anything from three to ten jupiter
masses
this rather falls short of starting a
thermonuclear reaction but quite enough
to keep the heat effectively trapped
inside the planet
taking into account our knowledge about
natural laws we can predict what the
conditions on the astronomical body's
surface are like
for example according to research by
david john stevenson from the university
of california in the u.s gas giants
similar to jupiter don't cool off
instantly after receding from their star
their thick hydrogen atmosphere is quite
reliable thermal isolation while the
dense and hot nucleus made up of
metallic hydrogen can keep the planet
heated for a considerable time
estimates show that the temperature of
the lowest strata of a hypothetical
celestial object's atmosphere may be
high enough for liquid water to be
around
it is likely to be present in the
atmosphere as giant clouds made up of
tiniest droplets
these deductions agree with the results
of mathematical modeling of wise
0855-0714
carried out by a team of scientists from
the university of edinburgh it showed
that the most likely temperature value
of the planet's surface is 250 kelvin or
23 degrees celsius below zero
the celestial body's atmosphere also has
a comparatively warm layer around 100
kilometers thick whose density
fluctuates from 0.4 to 1.2 milligrams
per cubic centimeter
it is comparable with the conditions on
the earth and so it is thought that this
environment should be favorable for
potential organic life
incidentally a planet doesn't have to be
a massive gas giant to avoid freezing in
the cosmos in 2020 a rogue planet
candidate was detected using
gravitational microlensing techniques
and here is the long designation it got
it is still awaiting confirmation of the
rogue planet status and its parameters
have been defined only generally so far
according to preliminary data however
the object is comparable to the earth in
terms of its mass
and is anything from 30 to 180 000 light
years away
according to our current scientific
notions
an object with a mass like that is not
supposed to be a gas giant and is more
likely to be a rocky planet
this in its turn offers good grounds to
believe that the object formed in the
protoplanetary disk of a planetary
system as the latter was forming it may
have been ejected from the system as a
result of a cataclysm in space or
alternatively under the influence of a
larger neighbor
after that it was left to its own
devices and so became a free-floating
planet
what will happen to it next is
predefined by a combination of several
factors
provided the object's atmosphere is
sufficiently dense it will be reliably
thermally isolated
potentially a layer of ice on its
surface could produce the same isolating
effect
in addition with the object's interior
scorching hot and with radioactive
elements undergoing decay
most of the hypothetical ocean will
remain in a liquid state
if the planet happened to have a moon it
may have retained it on ejection
if this is the case tidal forces are
likely to continue to deform and warm up
the lithosphere
theoretically with any luck primitive
anaerobic life forms may have stayed
around although of course it would be
next to impossible to discover their
traces now
most of the data about the rogue planets
we know today were arrived at following
mathematical modelling and complex
calculations
it was possible to do these calculations
thanks to the tiniest bits of
information gleaned with the help of
orbital and earth-based telescopes
even as i speak a project is being
worked on known as cleopatra
its main objective will be to search for
free-floating planets and other objects
in space with subsequent definition of
their parameters
the project relies on something called
microlensing it is a phenomenon when a
celestial body passes between a remote
star and the observer on the earth and
briefly interferes with the light
emitted by the remote star in the
background
when observed from different angles the
moment of transition will be registered
a fraction of a second sooner in one
observatory than in another referred to
as lensing parallax this effect allows
scientists to gauge the distance to a
detected object as well as its mass and
dimensions
an interplanetary spacecraft is planned
to be created within the project
it is supposed to blast off the surface
of the earth as soon as in 2025
alongside a mission to mars
after which it will enter its own orbit
around the sun
the project will be aided by specialized
artificial intelligence component whose
mission will be to process and analyze
collected information
the cleopatra project will certainly
delight us with a wealth of exciting and
important information so there is a lot
to look forward to
what is to become of all those rogue
worlds out there
drifting quite by themselves in the dark
depths of the universe
in theory a northern planet may be
captured by the gravitational field of a
star and become part of its planetary
system
but this chance is by all accounts
minuscule
most objects like that are destined to
wander for billions of years through
endless expanses of space
while slowly and inevitably cooling off
eventually
there to be swallowed up by black holes
or else destroyed as a result of a
cataclysm in space never to reveal their
secrets to mankind
the exact number of galaxies in the
universe is not known for certain yet it
is supposedly well over several hundred
billion
galaxies may be of all sorts of
different shapes
as for the main varieties they include
elliptical spiral lenticular and
irregular galaxies
there are sub categories for these as
well
the milky way for example is a barred
spiral galaxy
since any galaxy consists of a great
number of stars these objects masses may
reach incredible values
the mass of the dwarf galaxy segway 2
for example is just 550 000 times that
of the sun
as for the supergiant elliptical galaxy
ic1101
it is
1700 times heavier than the milky way
together with its immediate neighbors
our galaxy comprises what is known as
the local group it includes over 50
galaxies three of which are quite large
in comparison to the others
these are the milky way the andromeda
galaxy and the triangulum galaxy
the diameter of the local group measures
approximately 10 million light years and
its mass is about 3 trillion times that
of the sun
together with a few other galaxy
clusters of more modest dimensions the
local group in its turn comprises the
local sheet
a flat cloud with a diameter measuring
approximately 23 million light years
it is about 5 million light years thick
the local sheet forms part of the virgo
supercluster a vast element of the
large-scale structure of the universe
the local group is conditionally divided
into four parts
the first one is the subgroup of the
milky way comprised of our galaxy and
its satellites which may be either dwarf
galaxies or star clusters
the milky way is the second largest
galaxy in the cluster
according to today's estimates it
contains 200 to 400 billion stars as
well as from 25 to 100 billion brown
dwarfs
our galaxy has a spiral structure and
appears to be a disc with a diameter
measuring about 200 000 light years
at the same time
its thickness is just around a thousand
light years
still there is a bulge at the center of
the disc with a diameter of around 27
000 light years a supermassive black
hole with a mass of as much as 4.3
million times that of the sun is
supposedly concealed inside the bulge
a smaller black hole is said to be
orbiting it whose mass is anything from
one to ten thousand times that of the
sun
it is posited that it is dark matter
that accounts for most of the mass of
the milky way which is why it is
impossible to estimate it at this point
according to the latest estimates
however the mass of our galaxy is
approximately 1.5 trillion times that of
the sun
going slightly further from the milky
way we can observe its 31 satellites
these are mostly irregular shaped dwarf
galaxies they get so twisted and bent in
every which way on account of the
gravitational influence of their massive
neighbor
our closest satellite is the dwarf
galaxy cma dwarf which can be found in
the canis major constellation
it lies 25 000 light years away from the
earth and 42 000 light years from the
center of our galaxy
appearing like an elongated ellipsis
this dwarf galaxy contains supposedly
around one billion stars most of which
are red giants
due to the gravitational influence
exerted by the milky way the canis major
galaxy has almost broken apart
tidal forces had the following
disrupting effect the stars torn out
from the galaxy came to form the
so-called monocerous ring an elaborate
ring-shaped structure that traps around
the milky way
unfortunately observation of cma dwarf
is greatly thwarted by gas and dust
clouds floating between the galaxy and
our earth
the largest satellite of the milky way
and the fourth largest galaxy in the
local group is the large magellanic
cloud it is located as far as about 163
000 light years containing approximately
30 billion stars it has a diameter of
just seven times as little as that of
our galaxy
at the same time the cloud's mass is 300
times as little as that of the milky way
the explanation for such a stark
contrast is this the large magellanic
cloud does not happen to contain a
supermassive black hole in the center
besides there are great amounts of dark
matter in the milky way's galactic halo
the large magellanic cloud is an sbm
type which is in between dwarf spiral
and irregular galaxies
even though the gravitational influence
exerted over it by its massive neighbors
has as well as erased almost all traces
of its former spiral structure the bar
in the center remains to be clearly
distinguishable
there are a few especially notable
objects located in the large magellanic
cloud
for example the star r136a1
lying
165 000 light years away is the heaviest
star ever detected
this blue supergiant's mass is 315 times
that of the sun
and its surface temperature is as
scorching as over 40 000 kelvin the
luminosity of r136a1
is 8.7 million times that of the sun the
large magellanic cloud is also home to
one of the largest stars in the
investigated parts of the universe
the diameter of the red giant
wohg 64 is over one and a half thousand
that of the sun
this is just 25 percent less than the
diameter of the largest supergiant ever
detected
stevenson 2-18
according to today's accepted concepts
of stellar evolution
woh g64 is currently in the final stage
of its life and is expected to go
supernova at any moment in the next
several thousand years
when speaking about the milky way
subgrip of course we can't but mention
the virgo stellar stream
occupying approximately five percent of
the entire sky it appears as an
exceptionally scattered and dim flow of
several hundred thousand stars on the
outskirts of our galaxy according to the
overwhelming majority of scientists the
virgo stellar stream is remnants of a
dwarf spherical galaxy that has at some
point almost completely been swallowed
up by the milky way
moving yet further we will soon
encounter the galaxy known as andromeda
or the andromeda nebula
together with its satellites it forms
part of the local group referred to as
the andromeda subgrip
the galaxy lies as far as around 800
kilopas sex or two and a half million
light years we transit the status of our
closest neighboring galaxy which isn't a
dwarf one
the diameter of the andromeda nebula
measures approximately 220 000 light
years which is slightly more than that
of the milky way with its star count of
around a trillion there are three to
five times as many of them in it as
there are in our galaxy
interestingly the masses of the two
galaxies are more or less the same at
around one and a half trillion solar
masses
the point is that the stars forming the
andromeda nebula are an average elder
and lighter than those of the milky way
andromeda is one of our closest
neighbors
appearing as an elongated light spot it
is also one of the few galaxies visible
to the naked eye
interestingly its angular diameter is
six times that of the moon
the andromeda nebula is a spiral galaxy
with two clearly defined arms
it is peculiar for its binary core
when we observe it through a telescope
we noticed two clearly seen star
clusters in the center of the galaxy
with a distance between them around 5
light years
according to one of proposed theories at
some point andromeda swallowed up
another galaxy capturing its core
another supposition has it that there is
after all just one core with some part
of it obscured by a dust cloud
it is estimated that the overall mass of
the central part of this galaxy is over
140 million solar masses
there are approximately 400 globular
clusters in the andromeda nebula which
is about two to three times as many as
the rye in the milky way this means that
it probably swallowed up quite a few
dwarf galaxies in the past and the
clusters it contains now are the
remnants of their cores
andromeda has around 30 satellites the
ones that stand out are dwarf spiral
galaxies designations m32 and m110
some theories suggest that m32 round the
andromeda nebula several billion years
ago leaving a gargantuan hole in its
structure
this had a serious effect on m32 as well
with a substantial part of this galaxy
becoming andromeda's galactic halo
the milky way is estimated to collide
with andromeda in around 5 billion years
time today it is still quite impossible
to model this tremendous encounter and
its consequences accurately
but it is bound to be a truly
spectacular sight
the third large representative of the
local group is the triangulum galaxy it
is twice as little as the milky way in
size and has no confirmed satellites but
some dwarf galaxies of the local group
may well be gravitationally bound to it
the triangulum galaxy is not likely to
boast a supermassive black hole in its
center
the diameter of the galaxy measures
approximately 50 000 light years
the distance between triangulum and the
milky way is 2.7 to 3 million light
years
the galaxy also contains the ngc 604
nebula which is the largest known area
in space where stars are actively born
the stellar nursery's diameter reaches 1
300 light years
around 200 supergiants with a total mass
of a hundred thousand solar masses are
compactly grouped here
these stars are young and hot with their
powerful luminosity ionizing the gas the
star cluster is enveloped in this gives
the gas a bright glow which in its turn
makes the nebula appear quite bright
apart from the objects mentioned there
are other ones in the local group which
don't fall into any of the mentioned
subgroups
as a rule these are remote dwarf
galaxies and star clusters not tightly
gravitationally bound to any of the
three large galaxies
the galaxy ic-10 can be singled out here
lying approximately 2.2 million
light-years away from the sun
it is the only galaxy of the local group
where stars are actively born
ic-10 is shrouded in a hydrogen outer
envelope whose radius is much bigger
than that of the galaxy itself
the stellar disk of ic10 meanwhile
rotates in the direction opposite to
that of the outer envelope
with their mind-boggling dimensions of
hundreds of thousands of light-years on
end
even the largest galaxies remain tiny
dots in the large-scale structure of the
universe
the distances between them are
staggeringly enormous
and even light takes millions of years
to reach the closest of them
nevertheless we can still observe and
study them
there are innumerable riddles lurking in
the cosmos and mankind keeps solving
them one after another without flagging
zest
because every new discovery is just
another step in our cognition of the
universe
it goes without saying that to detect a
celestial object that absorbs all light
shed on it is a challenging task to say
the least that is why there are not that
many confirmed black hill candidates
today
still mathematical modelling shows that
their number in our galaxy may reach a
hundred million
this may seem an incredibly big number
but since there are 200 to 400 billion
stars in the milky way it makes us
realize that in all these expanses black
holes are objects one doesn't come
across that much
in one of our previous videos on the
topic we mentioned that a star the
progenitor of a black hole has to have a
mass of at least 18 to 20 solar masses
only this will ensure a powerful enough
supernova to compress the scorching hot
core of the star to an exceptionally
dense clump of material
after this has occurred nothing will be
able to stand up to the object's gravity
force and escape beyond the boundaries
of a conventional sphere predefined by
the so-called schwarzschild radius
what used to be a star transforms into a
bizarre object with an inner makeup that
would defy description by the physical
laws we're familiar with
the object referred to as a0620-0
or v-616 is one of the black holes
closest to our earth that we know of
it lies 3
300 light years away from our planet and
forms part of a binary star in the
constellation monocerous
the other object in the system is an
orange dwarf with a mass half that of
the sun
every 7.75
hours it completes a full orbit around
an invisible object of unknown nature
estimates show the mass of this
invisible object to be around 6.6 times
that of the sun
it is admittedly too much for a neutron
star
this leads one to believe that the
bizarre invisible object is more likely
than not a black hole
in addition to getting deformed and
elongated by the more massive neighbor's
gravity the orange dwarf is also getting
stripped of the outer layers of stella
mata
spiraling streams of scorching gas
gradually flow to the black hole and
form a bright accretion disk
it is thanks to this dazzling disk that
the black hole was detected
there are at least several dozen stars
in the environs of v616
some of which almost certainly have
their own planetary systems
it is highly likely that in the future
one of these stars will get dangerously
close to the black hole and as a result
will be sucked in by the objects
object's insane gravity
this unfortunate star will have no
choice and in this case the same slow
demise is eventually awaiting the black
hole's new companion as that of its
current one
the process of interaction of a black
hole with other objects largely depends
on their mass ratio
the smaller the distance between them
and the more massive the black hole the
stronger the influence of its tidal
forces over its companion
the star may be deformed by them and get
stretched towards the system's common
mass center
they can also form channels that would
carry stellar matter closer to the black
hole adding up to its accretion disk
if the tidal forces happen to be strong
enough they may well destroy the object
that is being sucked in by turning it
into a fiery ring
it is assumed that there may be planets
orbiting a black hole just as if it were
a regular star
in contrast to a widespread opinion
black holes are actually not able to
suck in all objects around them
indiscriminately
from the point of view of gravitation in
astronomical terms they behave just like
any star with the same mass
that is why incredibly though it may
seem a black hole may well have a stable
planetary system
there are several ways for them to form
firstly new celestial objects may
originate in a nebula of gas and dust
that is formed after a supernova
influenced by gravitation they're first
form clumps of material that collide
with each other and attract cosmic dust
as a result they eventually turn into
planets and satellites as well as large
numbers of small celestial objects like
asteroids and comets
the radiation of the black holes
accretion disk may be powerful enough to
warm them and even melt ice on their
surfaces
hypothetically a planetary system like
that could be favorable enough for life
to originate and with any luck
evolve
secondly when a black hole captures and
destroys another planetary system some
of its objects may choose to take up
stable orbital positions around their
new host
of course this makeover would bring
about dramatic changes on the celestial
object's surfaces
thus an ice giant may transform into an
ocean planet and a gas giant may lose
almost all of its hydrogen and turn into
a thonian planet
thirdly
space wanderers like rogue planets or
interstellar asteroids may also be
ensnared by the massive object's gravity
even though systems like that have not
yet been discovered in practice
there is no reason to suppose they're
non-existent
if on the other hand a planet is too
close to the system's center and the
black hole is massive enough other
factors come into play
a scorching hot stream of material
forming the accretion disk will strip
the celestial object of its atmosphere
and its friction will slow it down and
pull it still closer to the black hole
eventually extremely powerful tidal
forces will rip the planet to tiny
shreds
the debris will be pulled into the
accretion disk
and gradually melt in the hot gas around
in the end they will inevitably get
swallowed up by the black hole and in
essence become part of it
it is posited that there are three main
types of black holes to be found in the
universe that are different first and
foremost in terms of their mass
the first type can be found in the
center of most spiral galaxies
these are gargantuan black holes with
masses reaching several billion solar
masses
the density of matter in the central
part of a galaxy is generally extremely
high
which is the reason why they originate a
big number of large and bright stars
quite closely packed as they rapidly
burn out they transform into black holes
which in their turn rapidly grow and
often merge with each other
as a result supermassive objects are
born which are surrounded with giant
accretion disks made of scorching hot
material
they illumine space so brightly that it
makes them seen from billions of light
years away even if their galaxy is
completely unobservable to toss
these objects are known as quasars
the second type is much more widespread
but at the same time black holes like
these are not that easily detectable
their masses are close to those of stars
and they form out of large stars at the
end of the latter's life cycle
by devouring other celestial bodies and
interstellar gas these objects gradually
gain in size and eventually turn into
intermediate mass black holes
they can also merge together which
generates gravity waves that distort
space many light years around
the third type is the hypothetical
primary black holes
their existence has been inferred from
today's theory of universes origins and
evolution
fluctuations and matter that filled
space in its early stages of evolution
may have been favorable for black holes
of infinitely small size to originate
it should be mentioned that according to
estimates the smaller an object of this
type the faster it evaporates
and at the end of its life cycle it
turns into a tremendously powerful
electromagnetic impulse modeling shows
that primary black holes with masses
around 10 to the power of 12 kilograms
are supposed to be flaring up sometime
around now
but to date no such event has been
registered yet
according to a certain hypothesis a
microscopic black hole may form on
collision of extra high energy
elementary particles
this variety is referred to as quantum
black holes
still the conditions necessary for such
an event to happen are impossible to be
reproduced in lab conditions and
estimated life expectancy of these
hypothetical objects is so small that it
can hardly be measured with today's
latest and most advanced methods that is
why quantum black holes still officially
exist only in theory
of course it is extremely difficult to
detect such dark and compact objects
some of them happen to have a star
companion whose anomalous trajectory of
movement gives telltale prompts of there
being an invisible thing in close
proximity
another popular method of detection is
observation of accretion disks
these objects spectra have some typical
features that allow telling them from
other sources of light in space
sometimes we're lucky enough to get a
snapshot of a disk with a black spot in
it that is evidence that the observed
object's structure is quite unusual
a black hole may also be detected thanks
to the gravitational microlensing effect
this involves detecting the massive
invisible object as it transits between
the earth and a remote star this changes
the star's spectrum in a special way
but admittedly
this method requires a number of rare
factors to successfully work
there is hardly any doubt that space is
filled with great numbers of objects
that are dark and not easily noticeable
there may be wandering black holes among
them
these mysterious objects roaming around
in interstellar space and absorbing
every bit of light they come across
will probably never reveal their secrets
to us
the solar system is just one of the
countless multitude of planetary systems
scattered across our galaxy
as we know it consists of a single star
in its main sequence stage and date
planets with their satellites
in addition our system contains over a
million small celestial bodies like
asteroids comets and meteoroids the
planet in the solar system lying
furthest at least that we know of is
neptune
its orbits radius measures around 30
astronomical units which is equivalent
to approximately four light hours
amazingly only a tiny portion of the
solar system is encompassed by neptune's
orbit
the remotest object in the system
discovered to date is the so-called far
far out lying 132 astronomical units or
18 light hours away from the sun
still even this object barely visible
against a dark background of
unfathomable space is not at all close
to the hypothetical oort cloud whose
inner boundaries lie approximately 2 000
astronomical units away from the center
of our system
according to some estimates its outer
boundaries stretch for up to 60 000
astronomical units at the very least
which is around one light year
these limits are predefined by the sun's
gravitational influence and what lies
beyond is interstellar space
moving further away we will notice over
50 of all kinds of stars within 20 light
years from the sun
these stars are really diverse
from dim and cold brown dwarfs to bright
and widely known objects like sirius
procyon and daltaire
some of them have their own planetary
systems with objects potentially capable
of nursing and sustaining life
for example the object known as gliese
832c
which is 16.1 light years away from the
sun is similar to our earth more than
any other planet within the solar system
that we know of
the average temperature on the exoplanet
surface reaches 253 kelvin or 20 degrees
celsius below zero and it takes the
astronomical body just 36 earth days to
complete a full orbit around its parent
star
in astronomical standards the distance
between us and gliese 832c is relatively
small
however a space probe setting out from
our system at a speed of roughly 17
kilometers per second would take as much
as 300 000 years to reach the
exoplanet's environs
at our current level of technological
advancement it is impossible to design
an interstellar spaceship capable of
completing as long a journey as that
the solar system together with its
neighbor stars is part of the orion arm
the latter in its turn is part of the
milky way
it contains around 400 billion stars
and potentially over a trillion
exoplanets of all sorts can be
discovered there according to estimates
today
the main diameter of the milky way
measures around a hundred thousand light
years and the stellar halo may be twice
as large even though the thickness of
the main disc measures about a thousand
light years there is a clearly defined
bulge in the galaxy's center
this bulge is roughly 3 000 light years
thick
the milky way is part of the so-called
local group
this is a vast structure comprising over
50 galaxies concentrated within an area
of space measuring around 10 million
light years in diameter
the andromeda galaxy the triangulum
galaxy and the milky way are the largest
of the lot
some estimates show that the mass total
of the cluster may reach as much as 3
trillion solar masses with our galaxy
and andromeda accounting for the major
part
with the distance from the earth to
andromeda around 2.5 million light years
it is considered to be our closest
galaxy not counting smaller or dwarf
ones
moving on to the next order the local
group forms part of the giant virgo
supercluster made up of over 30 000
galaxies the supercluster is located
within an area of space with a diameter
of around
150 million light years
its mass total is as much as a
quadrillion solar masses
or in other words
around a thousand galaxies like the
milky way
the supercluster is quite flattened and
around 60 percent of all the objects it
is made up of appear like a flat sheet
around 10 million light years thick
staggering though it may appear on the
face of it
this value is actually small in terms of
the large-scale structure of the
universe
as we zoom out still more we have a
chance of seeing a giant supercluster of
galaxies approximately 520 million light
years in size
called laniakea it includes several
galaxy superclusters
among others the virgo supercluster and
the great attractor
the overall mass of this formation
measures approximately as much as a
hundred quadrillion solar masses the
great attractor lies roughly 250 million
light years away from our planet and is
the gravitational center for all objects
lying close by astronomical standards
it cannot be observed from the earth
directly as the milky way is plain
thwarts it that is why the nature of the
great attractor still remains an
unsolved mystery today
laniakea is part of the large-scale
structure of the universe an elaborate
system of galactic filaments walls and
voids gargantuan areas of emptiness in
space
some of these objects are really
incredibly enormous
for example the hercules corona borealis
great wall stretches for around a
staggering 10 billion light years
ever since its discovery in 2013 this
superstructure has been considered the
most gigantic component of the
large-scale structure of the universe to
all appearances it must be home to
millions of galaxies
and the number of stars it contains will
probably always defy calculation
the mere existence of a structure like
that is a mystery to science as
according to today's accepted theory of
universe's evolution
gargantuan clusters like that are simply
not supposed to form
but incidentally this wall so enormous
that the human brain cannot fully
appreciate its dimensions is still just
a tiny portion of the observable
universe
according to today's cosmological
notions
space in the universe is continually
expanding
with the speed of expansion depending on
the distance between objects the further
an observed object lies away from the
observer the faster the distance between
the two increases
the rate at which the two mutually
recede is not limited by the speed of
light because it's actually space matter
that is expanding
which means that at a certain point the
two objects will be mutually
unobservable
relic radiation observation shows that
the area of the observable universe is a
sphere
with a diameter roughly 93 billion light
years
according to the theory of relativity we
can see and interact with only those
objects that are within this sphere this
conventional spherical area in space is
called the meta galaxy and it may be
either all of the universe or again its
tiny portion
for all we know hypothetically there may
well lie some unknown structures beyond
the visible boundaries of space
such entities are referred to as
extrametagalactic objects and
unfortunately it is impossible to study
them today with scientific methods
still some astronomical bodies on the
edge of the visible universe appear to
be moving in ways different from what we
would naturally expect judging by the
data we have
instances of anomalous movements like
those may be evidence of the presence of
some massive structures beyond the mata
galaxy boundaries their attraction
pervades the space around and influences
objects around too
there is a whole plethora of hypotheses
as to the structure of the universe
beyond the meta galaxy but most of them
are rather of metaphysical nature
for example some people believe that
time and space as we more or less know
them are non-existent beyond the
boundaries of the universe
the physical laws we're used to do not
apply there either and notions of matter
material or energy are virtually
senseless
this hypothesis is further elaborated on
by the following idea
the meta galaxy accounts for just a part
of a yet more complex and larger scale
superstructure in space whose makeup and
dimensions are too incredible for us to
imagine it is quite possible that this
structure could be in a
multi-dimensional space
or else be based on physical principles
we have no idea of
this makes the mata galaxy just an
insignificant addition to or a partial
reflection of this mind-boggling
superstructure
according to some interpretations of the
anthropic principle there are other
worlds out there beyond the boundaries
of the observable universe
in those worlds the values of the
fundamental constants like the speed of
light or the electron charge are
completely different
this hypothesis is in many ways
supported by the idea of a multiverse
which schematically appears as foam with
lots of bubbles separated from each
other by thin balls but these walls are
impenetrable
this makes every universe a separate
space with its own physical laws
and for all we know these laws may be
totally different from the ones we're
used to
the most radical hypotheses go as far as
to deny our world any objective reality
whatsoever
according to these the universe is just
a simulation like virtual reality and
computers but on an incredibly advanced
level
as a rule
ideas like that imply that there is some
super beings or super civilizations out
there beyond the reality we're used to
whose level of advancement is infinitely
higher than ours and whose goals and
capabilities are arcane and
incomprehensible however it goes without
saying that it is hardly possible to
either confirm or repudiate these
hypotheses
[Music]
of course distances in space defy our
imagination and are even frightening
they appear infinite from the point of
view of any person today
what we do know is that the universe is
expanding and provided this process
continues there will come a point when
space objects will disappear one after
another beyond the event horizon
first galaxies then stars and the world
will immerse in eternal darkness
but by then there will be no one around
to witness that
of course the scale of space can't but
amaze
but it is even more incredible to
realize that mankind is capable of
creating technologies that enable us to
see the rich diversity of astronomical
objects
every day brings us new exciting
discoveries and step by step science is
constantly advancing and this means that
there are a lot more great trips around
the universe up ahead
[Music]
you